and tonight in a possible effort to
Shield President Biden from a
congressional investigation director Ray
is refusing to hand over that official
1023 document that purportedly describes
a criminal foreign bribery scheme from
Biden's time when he was vice president
now FBI officials have been in
possession of these allegations since
June of 2020 they have also been in
possession of Hunter Biden's laptop
since December of 2019 they have seen
emails and texts from Hunter Biden
detailing possible foreign payouts to
the big guy and half the money going to
Pops and complaining about paying for
Pop's home repairs bills now the FBI is
also fully aware of the dozens upon
dozens of suspicious activity reports
filed two Banks all linked to the Biden
family Syndicate yet no charges no doj
the special counsel no search warrants
from the FBI in fact Chris Ray is now
obstructing a congressional
investigation so you see what's
happening here this is your two-tiered
system of justice Now worse than ever
now despite a mountain of evidence of
public corruption the FBI the doj they
have been protecting and continue to
protect the Biden family just like
Hillary Clinton was protected in 2016
and before that the Clinton Foundation
was protected at the very same time
after an unprecedented SWAT style raid
at the home of former president Trump
the doj is apparently moving at
lightning speed to prosecute Donald
Trump why over some documents stored in
a secure room that the FBI had had
access to months earlier at Mar-A-Lago
from Trump's time in the white house now
today former president Trump's attorney
met with the special counsel Jack Smith
and other doj officials and what many
now believe is a precursor to an
indictment maybe as early as this week
according to reports the Federal grand
jury has been hearing evidence in this
case they are expected to meet again
this week and breaking tonight's sources
close to this program are also learning
that there is consideration of a
possible Hunter Biden indictment this
week if not the same day as a possible
Trump indictment my sources say
Obviously the justice department is
extremely nervous this will be viewed
properly as political retribution so now
the question is how much is politics
really a factor in the Biden justice
department now of course Trump's last
name or Clinton or Biden he'd never be
charged in any document probe his place
wouldn't have gotten raided it would
have never gotten this far Hillary we
all know she mishandled top secret
classified material on private servers
likely hacked by foreign countries she
then deleted 33 thousand subpoenaed
emails wiped those devices clean with
something we had never heard of called
bleach bid she removed SIM cards from
the phones and and blackberries and had
them destroyed with hammers but
according to James Comey no reasonable
prosecutor would bring charges against
Hillary Clinton now keep in mind another
special counsel is investigating Joe
Biden over the exact same issue except
Biden allegedly mishandled classified
material in multiple unsecured locations
including secret documents from Biden's
time even going back as far as him being
a senator but surprise surprise that
case appears to be going nowhere there
are no impending charges no grand jury
that we know of and by the way there's
been no leaks at all whatsoever in
contrast the document investigation into
Donald Trump has been riddled with
never-ending leaks disclosures including
FBI photographs from inside Mar-A-Lago
all designed to embarrass and impugn the
former president this is a Brazen level
of political bio and Corruption at the
FBI and the doj now think about it the
Biden doj is now preparing to charge Joe
Biden's Chief political opponent heading
into an election year Donald Trump with
the very same crime that he himself is
under investigation for all while Biden
you know walks away scot-free now that
is what you would expect from a Banana
Republic not from the United States and
sadly that extends far beyond Donald
Trump and it's been going on for quite
some time in 2005 you might recall House
Majority Leader Tom DeLay remember he
was indicted he was convicted in a
far-left district on bogus conspiracy
charges he was sentenced to three years
in prison and was forced to resign from
Congress before his case was overturned
and acquitted by a higher court that was
an eight to one decision a few years
later in 2013 the IRS admitted that they
were targeting conservative groups for
extra scrutiny and special
investigations simply because of their
political affiliations and then in 2014
GOP Rising Star then Virginia governor
Bob McDonald he was indicted on cooked
up federal corruption charges and
prosecutors attempted to put McDonald
behind bars for 12 years he lost his job
he lost his house he lost his marriage
before the U.S Supreme Court overturned
the conviction that was a unanimous
decision and in 2016 Donald Trump and
many of his associates they were
targeted by an FBI investigation all
based on a Russia hoax a hoax propagated
by the Clinton campaign and echoed all
over the mainstream media mob countless
lives were ruined millions of dollars
was spent all in legal fees reputations
were tarnished and many including Trump
witnessed their privacy violated in the
worst way imaginable in case after case
after case the process is the punishment
instead of investigating real crimes and
building strong cases investigators are
now putting Republicans and
conservatives through hell and that
means we have a two-tier justice system
so we have a serious problem at the FBI
and the doj a political rot that could
destroy our Republic could shred our
constitution meaning that there is no
equal justice under the law no equal
application of our laws no
self-awareness at the doj and the FBI
they think they're doing great they're
getting every Republican they can and
they're going after Donald Trump the FBI
by the way in a statement praised its
commitment to accommodating Comer's
request while denying The subpoena hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else